fiber is absolutely an essential
component to a healthy diet as opposed
to vitamins and minerals fiber seems
sorta meth not that big of a deal
however fiber offers a ton of health
benefits that vitamins and minerals
cannot Fiber has been shown to control
blood sugar levels lower LDL cholesterol
normalized the movement of stool for
your colon and reduce the risk of
constipation colon cancer diabetes and
hemorrhoids fiber comes in two flavors
soluble fiber and insoluble fiber
soluble fiber is found in foods like
oats peas carrots barley and fruit when
dissolved in water it makes a sticky
gelatinous material
hence it being soluble soluble fiber
molecules include Arab anak Ceylon fruit
tans and pectin insoluble fiber is found
in whole wheat flour corn vegetables
beans and nuts and is made of cellulose
hemicellulose and lignin though fiber is
fairly widespread across the food
spectrum it's entirely possible to live
on a diet without fiber this altered
diet would consist of protein fat and
sugar so pretty much just eating chicken
steak fish eggs cheese and milk and
ultra refined sugary foods like cake
cookies and ice cream with no fiber in
your diet the organ that's going to be
most affected will be your large
intestine followed by your small
intestine here's how your body works on
a high-fiber diet you ingest a fibrous
food say beans the food is ground and
churned in the stomach where it's made
into smaller particles passes through
your small intestine where 90% of the
nutrient absorption takes place and then
passes through your large intestine
throughout this whole journey the fiber
is mostly unchanged molecularly this is
because humans lack the digestive
enzymes to break down fibrous molecules
like cellulose and fruit Ann's cows and
other herbivores on the other hand do
have these enzymes instead humans have
bacteria in our colon that break it down
for us most bacteria that do this are
located in the sigmoid colon these
bacteria break down about 50 percent of
the fibrous material and release
hydrogen and methane gas as a by-product
the other 50% is extruded from your body
here's what happens when you don't eat
fiber for an extended period of time
Stage one Yukos will break down the gut
bacteria have no external food source to
live on in order to survive they break
down the mucosal lining of your colon as
the mucus is made of glycoproteins which
contains carbohydrates breakdown of the
mucous lining causes malabsorption and
inflammation of the colon leading to
diarrhea and constipation if you're
still excluding fiber in your diet then
we continue on to stage 2 selective
bacterial overgrowth the low fiber
environment selectively grows bacteria
that are able to thrive in low fiber
conditions such bacteria like e-coli are
especially tolerant of low fiber
environments and are able to outgrow
other bacteria they weren't able to
outgrow before because they had to
compete with other populations that were
living on the high fiber diet these low
fiber tau and bacteria feed on other
macromolecules like protein and lipids
which through your current diet are
quite plentiful yes ninety percent of
the protein and lipids are absorbed in
the small intestine however that 10%
that isn't absorbed is consumed by these
hearty bacteria and the final result of
not eating fiber is stage 3 intestinal
migration with no competition in sight
they continue to grow in migrate upwards
in your large intestine to find more
protein and lipids in your small
intestine large colonies of bacteria
aren't supposed to be here and when they
do colonize in the small intestine it
becomes a condition known as small
intestine bacterial overgrowth when
bacteria grow here the small intestine
responds by releasing a protein called
zon Yulin which opens the gut barrier
junctions of the intestinal wall oddly
enough this also happens to people who
have celiac disease by the way you can
learn more about celiac disease in my
video where I eat pure gluten so
basically when you have small intestine
bacterial overgrowth your body actually
mimics the symptoms of celiac disease
this causes consistent diarrhea
malabsorption of nutrients constipation
bloating inflammation and increases the
risk for colon cancer how does one know
they have small intestine bacterial
overgrowth
well the bacterial growth has to be
measured in the small intestine and the
only way to find out is to go there and
take
sample the bacterial sample is taken in
the Jew genome which is between the
duodenum and ileum of the small
intestine the procedure is known as
digital aspiration and involves sending
an endoscope down your esophagus Pasteur
stomach him through the initial length
of the small intestine from there a
mucous 'el sample is aspirated and
counted for bacterial colonies bacteria
populations in your colon where they're
supposed to be are typically over 100
trillion per milliliter whereas in the
small intestine it's usually no more
than 10,000 bacteria per milliliter any
bacterial samples above 20,000 per
milliliter is indicative of small
intestine bacterial overgrowth
luckily the fix for this is very simple
treatment with antibiotics and return to
a fiber rich diet however this could
have all been prevented if you just ate
your vegetables
[Music]